alors aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour un
sujet qui est un peu à part avec moi en
invité c'est à qui c'est évangéliste
bonjour et Kiss j'aurais bien tu as un
déco fondateurs de la marque nothing
c'est ça et puis on est venu aujourd'hui
pour parler de la marque essayer de
connaître un peu les coulisses savoir ce
qui se passe quand on crée une marque
qui part de zéro une marque que vous
avez créé en 2020 si je dis pas de
bêtises fin 2020 c'est bien ça je t'ai
connu à oneplus avant je sais que tu as
travaillé chez Sony avant aussi il me
semble c'est ça c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit
LinkedIn ce matin en fait et donc voilà
est-ce que tu peux toi un peu resituer
ce que tu fais au sein de nos signes ton
background et comment tu arrives là du
coup j'ai rejoint du coup l'aventure one
place au moment du oneplus 2 à l'époque
on avait uniquement un bureau à Shenzhen
en Chine après on va commencer à
développer tout le tout le marché
européen
et après j'ai ouvert également le
l'entité en France du coup c'était il y
a déjà
5 ans 5 ans et après bon les choses sont
plus ou moins bien passé mais ouais ça
c'était notre histoire majoritairement
j'étais responsable de plusieurs
lancements produits notamment le One
plus
[Musique]
vous avez commencé fin 2020 à créer la
structure et vous lancer le premier
produit c'est en septembre non juillet
août 2021 juillet 2021 alors comment
est-ce qu'on part d'une feuille blanche
même si on a une idée en tête et qu'on a
un peu j'imagine une vision sur là où on
veut aller avec un plan sur plusieurs
années mais comment on part 2-0 avec une
bonne idée je me dis un peu d'argent
mais pas des masses non plus il faut
enlever beaucoup et comment on arrive à
sortir en moins d'un an en produits
c'est quoi le truc en fait tout a
commencé on disait ok c'est vrai que on
a grandi avec le lancement de de l'iPod
du premier iPhone et quand rester
éveillé regarder l'équinoxe il y avait 6
une certaine excitation et c'est vrai en
finale cette expression c'est c'est
atténuant un petit peu tous les produits
qui avaient vraiment une zone très
similaire il y avait rien vraiment qui
sortait du lourd rien de très excitant
sur la un peu la standardisation de tout
ce qu'on retrouve au niveau mais là tu
me parles de quoi tu parles de
l'ensemble des produits tu me parles
vous avez commencé des écouteurs tu me
parles d'écouteurs tu me parles de
smartphone
que ce soit les écouteurs on est on
reste quand même il y a personne qui a
pris vraiment un parti pris sur
notamment aspect design qui est la
partie la plus visuelle vraiment qui
même quand on lance un produit par
exemple en fin le premier 70 c'est ce
qui ressemble au à la génération d'avant
du coup vraiment le parti pris design ça
a été pour nous quelque chose qu'on
avait à cœur dès le début et c'est pour
ça aussi qu'on a ramené ring au tout
début et les associés du coup de Nothing
assez rapidement on a réussi à avoir ce
cette idée de transparent qui allait
bien avec le nom ça vous est venu
comment cette idée ça vient d'être
genering ah c'était il y a du
brainstorming c'est vrai qu'on qu'on moi
ça fait des des années j'avais commencé
à travailler sur une collab avec un du
coin smartphone transparent qui est
jamais vraiment sorti etc donc c'est
c'était un petit peu dans ta tête depuis
un moment après c'est vrai que c'est
très compliqué c'est très compliqué de
faire des produits transparents parce
que du coup tous les composants font
maintenant partie de ton design donc tu
dois aller customiser chaque composant
qui est maintenant visible c'est pas
trop moche quoi voilà exactement il faut
qu'il soit même plutôt beau et du coup
du coup du coup au début on a commencé
avec du coup des des mots COP avoir un
petit peu ce que ça allait donner etc et
après une fois qu'on avait le une idée
en terme de design c'est c'est vraiment
le faire en sorte que d'une simple idée
ça devienne un produit final et là c'est
là où les choses se compliquent ou là tu
te rends compte qu'il faut que tu
trouves par exemple des supérieures qui
vont aller costumiser
pour ceux qui regardent des supérieurs
c'est quoi un des gros challenges en
industrie et qui rend la chose très
compliqué en tant que nouvelle marque
c'est que à chaque marque au final n'a
pas tous les composants in house ils ont
ils ont ils ont pas tout leur arène des
au sein de la marque etc c'est vraiment
une un réseau de supérieur et de
partenaires enfin que ça soit enfin
historiquement on sait très bien que
Samsung font les écrans des smartphones
Sony font les
capteurs etc donc batterie il y a on a
plus de 200 partenaires notamment sur
par exemple sur un smartphone ça
représente la donc tous les composants
etc ça représente plus de 200
partenaires un petit peu moins du coup
sur les écouteurs mais pareil il faut
aller chercher tous ces partenaires il
faut les convaincre à travailler avec
avec toi parce qu'au final tes nouvelles
marques ils ont pas forcément envie de
prendre le risque d'autant plus que
c'est une industrie ou on a vu plusieurs
marques qui ont essayé de se lancer ben
du coup ça a pas marché du coup tous ces
supérieurs perd pas mal de sous quand
quand une marque se lance sur qui
mettent d'accord à travailler avec eux
avec nos petites long terme et qu'au
final la marque ça se passe pas comme
prévu ben du coup ils perd des sous donc
ils sont très vigilants avec qui
travaillent et qui ne travaillent pas
donc du coup ça a été quand même un gros
travail pour s'assurer pour aller
trouver tous ses partenaires et pouvoir
développer et produire nos produits mais
ça c'est le réseau que vous aviez avec
oneplus avant qui a permis de trouver
ces de trouver ces gens-là c'est enfin
toute l'équipe des années d'expérience
dans l'industrie etc et c'est ça qui
nous a permis aussi de lever des fonds
dans un premier temps parce que même
avant d'aller chercher du coup tous les
partenaires il fallait lever des fonds
il faut montrer que tu es crédible il
faut montrer que tu as l'argent et que
avoir une bonne idée c'est bien mais ça
suffit pas derrière ça suffit pas parce
que on pas forcément citer si t'es
d’autres non mais on a vu des nouvelles
marques ou produits ça tenait plus ou
moins la route mais après le la
stratégie qu'on appelle goat to market
sur la partie lancement etc et pas
forcément l'expertise et on peut faire
un bon produit mais si le reste ça
suffit pas et c'est ça qui rend
également la chose beaucoup plus
difficile parce que il faut tout faire
par faire non tu peux pas juste
développer un bon produit et pas
s'assurer que la manière dont tu vas le
lancer les partenaires qui tu vas lancer
etc donc ça ça suit pas le produit va
quand même pas se vendre et on est dans
une industrie où il faut faire du volume
pour avoir justement la confiance de
tous les partenaires sur la chaîne
et pour avoir éventuellement des prix
préférentiels sur le long terme etc etc
parce que vous quand tu commences par
des écouteurs à 99 euros à l'époque le
tarif est pas non plus hyper élevé
j'imagine qu'il je sais pas si vous font
les meilleurs tarifs parce que vous êtes
un peu pas les outsiders mais vous êtes
les nouveaux venus même si en tant que
nouvelle marque tu as les pires
conditions c'est ça dure en termes de
prix tu vas payer plus cher que
une marque qui est déjà lancée qui fait
des des centaines de milliers de
produits tu vas avoir des ce qu'on
appelle les paiementers donc à quel
moment les composants doivent être payés
donc en tant que nouveau acteur sur
marché tu dois payer tous les composants
en amont attendu que si tu fais des
millions d'unités etc ben j'ai un monde
je paye les composants même après les
avoir reçus que tes produits sont que
tes produits sont assemblés et
limitations là tu commences à payer tes
partenaires en tant que nouvelle marque
zéro prise de risque auprès de toute la
splatchen et généralement faut payer une
grosse partie en amont alors comment tu
fais parce que pour ça il faut beaucoup
d'argent donc il faut que tu arrives les
gens alors vous avez levé auprès de qui
vous avez fait comment donc ça a
commencé tout simplement notamment il y
a cars car enfin en tant que
co-fondateur de wamplos et au moment où
il a quitté ou en place c'était ça
représentait quand même plusieurs
milliards de Venus annuels il y avait
une certaine expérience associée aussi
au nom et du coup en fait en parlant un
différent
c'est investisseur aussi des amis que ça
soit même quelqu'un comme question et
qui on avait bossé la wa en place et au
final ils ont ils partagent le même
sentiment sur le statut de l'industrie
sur le contexte de l'industrie que voilà
il y a plus vraiment une marque qui est
un certain niveau d'émotions enfin
quelque chose un petit peu de nouveau
quoi et du coup même si vous savez pas
comment forcément on allait faire ça etc
tout le monde était d'accord avec notre
point de vue on va industrer ils ont dit
ok ben en fait ces gars là ils ont déjà
fait ça fait des années qui font ça donc
s'il y a une équipe qui qui peut
éventuellement réussir c'est bien
celle-là donc on a réussi à avoir ouais
et que si Nesta Tony Fadel également
l'inventeur de l'iPod qui était très
proche du Steve Jobs impressionnant
aussi nous aide beaucoup énormément
d'expérience
Kevin Gleen aussi un des co-fondateurs
de twitch Steve Hoffman le covateur
ratio de Regis donc des Gaulois qui ont
investi du coup je crois le cylindre
c'était un peu plus 7 millions de
dollars ok ce qui est pas grand chose
suffisant pour pour commencer à se
lancer et après du coup il y a Google
Mathieu qui a qui
exactement
et qui va m'en séparer de Google et
voilà quoi on a pu vraiment du coup
début 2021 commence à développer ce Iwan
c'était mis d'accord sur l'identités
visuels la marque des produits compliqué
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte que au
final ça soit la colle qui est appliquée
entre les différents matériaux etc pour
pas qu'elle soit visible plein de
challenges associés à ce design qui
était certunique mais très compliqué à
faire et notamment à faire sur une
échelle une grande échelle on se parle
de plusieurs centaines de milliers de
produits et en termes de contrôle de
qualité etc chaque développement INDEXA
doit être doit être testé et compagnie
et du coup c'était beaucoup de beaucoup
de challenges sur sur un premier produit
et du coup qu'il fallait sortir aussi
assez rapidement parce que tu es limité
en terme de capital il faut sortir assez
rapidement pour
en espérant que ça marche pour pouvoir
lever par la suite c'est le produit qui
vous a permis de de financer le
smartphone en fait exactement d'accord
exactement l'idée c'est pour ça que vous
avez commencé par des écouteurs
exactement ça nous permettait ça reste
quand même un segment qui est assez
mature en termes de développement
du coup ça c'était vraiment on a eu
bosser cette
l'aspect différenciation notamment sur
le design et c'était un petit peu notre
quai study pourquoi pour pouvoir aller
lever plus
pour aller des montants beaucoup plus
élevés pour pouvoir éventuellement
produire le following quand tu as tout
un groupe d'anciens de oneplus qui part
et qui vont s'attaquer ensuite à sortir
un smartphone en juillet 2022 si j'ai
pas de bêtises il y a un an ce qui a un
moment vous avez pas un oneplus qui est
qui dit qu'est-ce qui nous font cela ils
vont voir nos partenaires vous êtes sur
Android donc vous allez forcément voir
Google pour travailler avec eux les
puces c'est du Qualcomm à un moment
est-ce qu'ils vont pas chercher à se
dire ok ces gens-là c'est bien mais
c'est un peu les personnes à parce que
ils sont bien sympas mais il y a un
moment risque de nous faire de bonbons
vous avez eu des soucis avec eux ou pas
non après ça reste ça reste quand même
un très gros groupe des nouvelles
marques c'est aussi une industrie qui
est très compliqué donc c'est pas
forcément ça reste quand même deux
marques de niveau différent après Google
et quoi comme ça a été en fin depuis le
début ils ont vraiment cru en insigne en
aventure nothing il nous a énormément en
termes de ressources sur les composants
sur la partie développement etc donc
c'est le partenaire là sont contents de
voir une nouvelle marque et d'autant
plus en termes de résultats on est la
marque Android qui a le plus gros taux
utilisateur qui viennent d'un iPhone ok
du coup bon même si on est en termes de
volume on est on est ça tu mesures
comment tu te mesures qu'on les gens
installent leur smartphone et qui
transfert de la data comment tu arrives
à savoir que ces gens ils viennent
passer de Google mais je pense c'est
c'est toujours des données anonymes mais
ils ont ils ont le moyen de savoir je
pense sur sur quel smartphone la
migration des choses comme ça
[Musique]
début d'année et là ça devient
intéressant parce que du coup on est on
est à peu près 100 ingénieurs sur la sur
la partie Software et même sur le 2 etc
on va voir un certain niveau
d'innovation avec notes 2.0 et on a une
belle rodemap qui va suivre maintenant
qu'on a qu'on a les reines entre les
mains sur sur notre os un moment est-ce
que tu dis est-ce que c'est foutu
l'histoire est-ce qu'on va y arriver
est-ce qu'on va pas y arriver il y a
forcément des moments où tu te dis je
pars de zéro et je dois commencer à
financer mon premier produit plus mon
deuxième produit la prise de risque est
toujours là j'imagine qu'il y a beaucoup
de capital personnels que toi et tous
les cofondateurs avaient mis dedans ce
qui a un matin tu dis bon voilà c'est
bon on va pas y arriver c'est mort trop
compliqué après voilà faut toujours y
croire etc mais ouais on a eu des
moments plus tendus que d'autres et
notamment sur les premiers produits il y
a toujours énormément de problèmes à
gérer
des soit sur le développement produit
que ça soit sur lancement sur c'est pas
un industrie facile après voilà on a
toujours on a toujours cru le premier
produit a vraiment montré qu'il y avait
l'appétit pour pour pour une nouvelle
marque encore une fois que ça soit
Google ou alcool on a des partenaires
qui nous poussent énormément qui nous
aident énormément donc on y a toujours
cru après c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
moments beaucoup plus compliqué que tu
as pu avoir je pense sur les deux
premières années de manière générale
c'est assez compliqué c'est assez
compliqué parce que tu as énormément de
choses à faire au développement produit
monter les équipes en même par exemple
tout bête mais même la portièreh on a
commencé à regarder ça sérieusement à
partir du moment où on était plus de 250
personnes ce qui est complètement fou on
est 450 personnes ok plus de 450
personnes dans cette cette bureaux à
travers le monde les produits première
génération il y a toujours énormément de
difficultés tu te rends compte
énormément de difficultés sur la partie
développement un timing qui est qui peut
pas être déplacé par exemple le
lancement du phone one on n'avait pas le
choix il fallait à tout prix lancer en
juillet parce que du coup comme tu payes
tous tes composants en amont il faut
être sûr de payer un moment donné mais
si du coup si tu si tu pousses le
lancement toi tu as déjà sorti
payer tous les ans maintenant mais en
fait tu pousses en fait à t’entrer ton
entrée de fermer ta porte il faut que ça
rentre exactement et le moins de Gap qui
entre les deux le mieux c'est et là du
coup en fait vraiment sur les produits
de deuxième génération là on est sur des
sites de planning développement produit
beaucoup plus long on va aller vraiment
chercher le détail soit sur la partie
design du même sur le fond de la manière
dont tu as des années le X2 c'était
beaucoup plus rigoureux que sur le fond
noir qui était un petit peu un process
un petit peu plus artistique voilà là on
avait vraiment une approche très soignée
avec un clé de système ce qu'on appelle
pour avoir une certaine symétrie et
beaucoup de terrassions etc donc ça
c'est qu'on n'est pas forcément le luxe
à l'époque de faire ça ça c'est pour
tous les les produits que ça soit
ailleurs de aussi pour moi c'est un
produit qui est hyper abouti on est
chercher vraiment un dernier niveau de
détails sur la partie design sur la
partie software également avec la
Notting ex on voit vraiment une vraie
montée en gamme
surtout les niveaux ce que vous avez
réussi avant de ce que vous voulez quand
tu lances un produit et un moment tu dis
bon ok on finance on financeit ça on
doit en vendre temps vous avez atteint
les objectifs ou pas là du coup il y a
annoncé une nouvelle vie de 96 millions
OK et tout simplement si il fait pas tes
objectifs tu vas pas pouvoir lever quoi
ok au final tu rentres on est en train
d'industrie les gens ont investi par
rapport à l'équipe qui avait en place
par rapport à ce qu'on avait fait c'est
la confiance pas forcément les faire et
c'était des promesses et des promesses
qu'il fallait remplir et ce à chaque
produit et en fait c'est chaque produit
qui nous a permis de d'aller toujours
plus loin et là c'est vrai que si on
regarde on a récemment passé le cap des
1.5 millions d'unités vendues
1,5 millions d'unités
et c'est ça vraiment qui nous a permis
aussi de tout simplement développer le
fond de c'est à dire si ça se passait
pas bien il y aurait pas eu de donc là
vous avez levé 96 millions de dollars
récemment ah oui on a annoncé
littéralement la semaine dernière
d'accord donc si on suit la logique de
ce que tu m'as dit c'est que si tu lèves
là de l'argent c'est pour les projets
futurs exactement ce qui va arriver
après exactement c'est pour ça donc du
coup les investisseurs ils regardent du
coup ils ont ils peuvent regarder le
fond d'eux voir juger le produit voir
qu'est-ce qui arrive par la suite
regarder la route map etc
on va voir tous les les fans shoplan
qu'on a en place etc et s'ils font
investir ou pas il y a aucune marche des
années qui s'est lancé dans cette
industrie qui a réussi à vendre 800000
unités son premier produit donc c'est en
soi même si c'est une gout dans l'océan
quand on regarde à l'industrie de
manière générale quand on regarde sur
les dernières années une nouvelle marque
s'est lancée c'est c'est du jamais vu et
c'est là que les investisseurs ils
disent qu'il y a quelque chose à faire
mais ça qui est intéressant parce que tu
me disais tout à l'heure en le constat
de base c'est de se dire on est dans une
industrie on prend notamment le Smart
mes écouteurs tous ressemblent donc du
coup il y a un peu une espèce de du côté
un peu un peu tristounet parce que bon
mise à part des fois des blocs photos
qui sont un peu différents mais il y a
pas de proposition qui soit un petit peu
sexy alors la question c'est en fait
est-ce que c'est les autres qui ont des
goûts de chat ou alors est-ce que c'est
vous qui avez une idée de génie et pour
se dire parce que en fait votre idée
elle est belle il y a déjà des marques
il y avait 6 je pense à Xiaomi qui a
essayé de sortir un smartphone avec un
dos transparent mais qu'en fait c'était
pas réellement un dos transparent
c'était un truc qui a été designé qui
ressemble à de transparent parce que ça
devait être un peu compliqué à
industrialiser l'histoire mais en fait
est-ce que c'est justement le fait de se
dire bon on veut faire un truc différent
on va chercher teenage genolin et eux
vont nous apporter le côté bon goût dont
on a besoin que les autres n'ont plus
aujourd'hui parce que c'est ça le truc
en fait pense c'est une approche de
manière générale c'est à dire tous ces
gros groupes qui marchent donc essayer
de faire un petit design transparent
par-ci par là mais il y a pas vraiment
une une vraie histoire racontée il y a
pas une vraie image de marque là en
commençant de zéro avec cette volonté de
faire un design différent c'était la
première étape c'est-à-dire quand tu
fais partie d'un grand groupe comme ça
niveau flexibilité sur ce qui peut être
fait c'est très minime et généralement
associé un petit peu de marketing mais
il y a pas vraiment un il y a pas il y a
pas de fond tandis que là on est du coup
on est rentré industrie en différentiant
sur la partie hardware en terme de
design par rapport au fait que le fond
noir a marché on a pu aussi construire
nos équipes en interne etc sur la partie
software donc là cette année gros focus
à la partie Software et amener un niveau
d'innovation et c'est ce qu'on va voir
également sur nothing OS 2.0 à plusieurs
rénovations et un vrai point de vue sur
l'expérience Android d'un regard d'un
garnissing et du coup ça ça valait plus
voir que ce qu'on avait sur le phone one
beaucoup plus loin beaucoup plus loin
avec une intégration ordoit software en
terme de ces visuels mais également une
vraie opinion sur qu'est-ce qu'on veut
rajouter en plus de l'expérience de base
Android et du coup ça ça permet en fait
de pouvoir innover tout simplement parce
que tu as quand même cette flexibilité
cette agilité en tant que nouvelle
marque de prendre des décisions qui
qu'un grand groupe pour qui tout tourne
ou qui ont l'habitude de faire certaines
choses et qui ont des dizaines de
milliers c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
donc nous on a une approche qui est un
petit peu niche tu vois nos produits ils
vont venir s'adresser à un certain à une
certaine audience à quelqu'un qui va
avoir un goût pour design qui va aimer
un petit peu l'aspect novateur du
produit il va apprécier l'expérience
software également maintenant c'est une
proposition un petit peu différente et
on arrive à grandir on a de plus en plus
utilisateurs il y a énormément d'intérêt
entre la marque et voilà et le plus on
arrive à continuer à faire grandir les
équipes avant des produits le plus on va
pouvoir aller plus loin en termes de
différer et d'innovation est-ce qu'il y
a pas un piège justement là-dedans en se
disant que plus vous allez le gros et
moins vous allez pouvoir être être
disruptif pour trouver un peu dans le
piège qu'on les autres aujourd'hui alors
bien comme j'ai bien compris vous êtes
pas parti peut-être avec la même vision
mais ce qui a un moment il y a pas un
piège à trop grossir et à casser un peu
ce côté startup hyper frais après c'est
sûr que ça ça que tu arrives à ce
moment-là et même elle a beaucoup qui
nous demande est-ce que vous vous votre
concurrent principal c'est Apple etc
bien évidemment que non on n'a pas ses
ambitions d'être l'iPod de 2023 et une
ambition éventuellement d'être l'Apple
des années
1990 voilà mais un aspect un petit peu
plus novateur quelque chose un petit peu
de différenciant raisonner auprès d'une
audience assez spécifique mais on est OK
avec ça et cette audience là suffit en
termes de volume est-ce qu'on a besoin
de faire pour pour une aventure entre
guillemets et pouvoir enlever plus de
fond et après voilà effectivement
peut-être je demande deux trois ans on
va commencer à élargir en termes de
gamme il y a différentes stratégies que
ça soit des sous marques il y a plein de
stratégies qui sont utilisés auprès
d'industrie de faire différentes
segments produits mais on a envie
vraiment de garder un petit peu notre
lignée si tu vas faire vraiment la
l'identité de marque pour nous c'est le
plus important et vraiment une cohérence
et je pense un petit peu ça aussi qui se
passe industrer c'est qu'il y a plus
vraiment d'identité bien évidemment de
la d'Apple il n'y a aucune marque il y a
une vraie identité de marque et
éventuellement c'est pas uniquement
marketing oui c'est produit jusqu'au
marketing et tout ce qui est ça qui est
bien avec nothing que ça soit produit et
marketing vente etc on a tous cette
notion que que la marque nothing est-ce
que ça représente c'est important et ce
pour tous les points
tous les bons
tu fais trop
enfin l'idée c'est chacun en fait ça
soit
avec la marque que ce soit produit et
que ce soit marketing etc que ce soit
vraiment cohérent je peux poser la
question je me disais aujourd'hui un
smartphone combien ça coûte je
t'explique pourquoi je te dis ça moi je
regarde extérieur sur le côté média à
regarder le marché avoir un peu ce qui
se passe tu as d'un côté un Xiaomi qui
va te dire nous on prend pas plus de 5%
de marge alors tu sais pas si c'est une
marge à l'année marche sur un produit tu
sais pas mais bon c'est le discours qui
est là et à contrario tu vois de l'autre
côté des Apple avec des budgets
marketing monstrueux ou tu dis ça fait
partie forcément du prix pour smartphone
s'inclus dedans quand on commence à
créer un smartphone tu me dis on paye
les composants plein bananes ça coûte
une fortune vous sortez un smartphone
qui coûtait écoutez combien le fun one
qu'on voulait sortir 499 499 euros qui
était une super proposition de valeur
avec de l'innovation avec un concept qui
était quand même un peu différent même
si ça ça smartphone il raconte une autre
histoire au final quand tu arrives et
que tu te lances sur un smartphone alors
je peux pas te demander combien ça coûte
de se produire ton smartphone mais en
fait c'est quoi le ratio entre tous les
coups qui sont bien fabrication de mon
smartphone et ce que j'arrive à me
dégager derrière un peu comme comme
pognon quoi c'est quoi le truc
c'est quoi c'est de la marge pour des
gens comme vous pouvez faire des volumes
monstrueux clairement on n'est pas du
tout dans une position on doit aller
vraiment maximiser la marge on va plus
maximiser le volume et s'assurer même si
voilà on a une proposition qui est
produit avec un petit peu novatrice
différente etc l'aspect rapport qualité
prix joue un rôle ultra important et
c'est très risqué de se dire ok bah je
vais me dégager une grosse marge en tant
que nouvelle marque sans forcément avoir
sans forcément avoir rien fait derrière
pour revenir à ta question
pour lancer si demain tu tiendras qui
sont à se lancer on va lancer un
smartphone il à peu près compter 50
millions de dollars en coût fixe
d'accord donc ça sans regarder le
Bangkok le Bangkok et du coup et le Bell
of mature donc le prix de chaque
composant mais vraiment en termes
d'investissement arnd payer les équipes
pour développer produit payer tout ce
qui est
tout ce qui est les différents brevets
etc enfin tu as plusieurs lignes de
coups tu as déjà un conflit 50 millions
ça c'est sans avoir sorti un smartphone
de l'usine bah c'est ça 50 millions déjà
tu dois poser sur la table sans avoir
vendu absolument exactement et après du
coup à chaque smartphone tu vas du coup
payer un coup pour pour le Biloque
nature qui est le coût de chaque
composant sur ce tu vas tu vas tu as
différents parties du coup que ça soit
partie SAV tu as un pourcentage qui est
associé jusqu'à la marge que tu vas
aller payer sur tes frais de tes
partenaires qui vont distribuer ton
produit et là tu arrives à un coût final
et tu vas rajouter également les taxes
etc etc donc au final tu as ta marge
et il reste pas grand chose et notamment
en tant que nouvelle marque après voilà
c'est un petit peu ça fait partie du jeu
pour l'instant nous focus c'est vraiment
la croissance le volume et après dès
qu'on aura aussi une grosse base
utilisateurs etc dans la tu peux avoir
tu peux faire des services notamment sur
la partie software etc pour commencer à
améliorer tes ton niveau de marche vous
visez quel volume sur la vente du fun
tout on n'a pas forcément un volume
spécifique en tête là on met on met
maximum juste on s'arrange un point de
Supply Chain pour avoir des
ces gens de Milestone sur ça nous donne
des Windows en termes de four casting
qui sont sur lesquels on peut être assez
précis donc là par exemple on va lancer
le smartphone si deux semaines et du
coup dès qu'on a les premiers chiffres
de données ben là il faut il faut
rajouter smartphone mais l'idée c'est
voilà encore une fois en tant que marque
on doit on doit continuer en 300 donc
l'année dernière on a fait 200 millions
de chiffre d'affaires donc sans
communiquer sur officielle bien
évidemment on ouvre l'objectif la
croissance moi de ce que j'en comprends
sur votre marque vous n'êtes pas une
marque qui est un produit vous avez plus
une marque qui est liée à l'innovation
il y a une histoire donc bien qu'en
commençant par des écouteurs en passant
par un smartphone parce que c'est
aujourd'hui le produit qui permettra de
d'attraper des consommateurs sur
d'autres catégories de produits en fait
c'est quoi un peu la frontière la limite
où vous irez pas est-ce que c'est lié
uniquement est-ce que vous allez réussir
à lever en fond est-ce que demain dans
10 ans 20 ans on peut peut-être penser
avoir une télé 9 lignes avec un design
totalement différent c'est quoi en fait
c'est ça c'est là que c'est que enfin
sinon c'est que une fois que tu as
réussi notamment faire un smartphone tu
vois c'est plus c'est plus 3000
composants c'est pour vraiment un des
produits sur le hardware le plus
compliqué à faire donc une fois que tu
arrives à avoir l'équipe à réussir sur
ce marché là après le reste c'est facile
entre guillemets mais voilà pour
l'instant il faut pas non plus trop se
disperser enfin tu vois là on a lancé le
fond de on a enfin une équipe software
etc mais il y a énormément transfert
même la vision software sur les sur les
trois prochaines années dingue il y a
vraiment une volonté de faire vraiment
quelque chose unique mais pas il va
falloir construire les équipes etc et
garder aussi un élément de Focus qui est
très important parce que généralement
quand tu dis ok là on a vendu un point
5000 ans de produits
on est des oufs entre guillemets et on y
va à fond les manettes mais pas du tout
pas du tout faut vraiment garder la tête
sur les épaules et garder quand même un
vrai focus sur le produit faire les
choses bien et pas aller trop vite
est-ce que vous allez sortir un
smartphone tous les ans pour l'instant
c'est c'est ce qui est prévu ok c'est ce
qui est prévu
on est dans un industrer quand même où
il y a énormément de lancement il y a
énormément de compétitions il faut
rester quand même en termes de
proposition pour les utilisateurs faut
rester sur un produit et faire de ce qui
se fait de mieux quoi où est-ce que sera
le signe dans 7 ans très très compliqué
à dire une Road back qui vous emmène un
peu loin c'est où le plus loin de votre
map voilà parce que trois prochaines
années trois prochaines années donc
quand tu vas avoir des investisseurs que
tu arrives à des 96 millions de dollars
ils ont une vision sur trois ans ok
c'est ça en terme de roadmap produit
après voilà il y a différents scénarios
également la différence qui sont
corrélés directement à différents
produits et notamment les smartphones
c'est-à-dire le smartphone le reste des
produits c'est limite très minime sur la
le planning de financehoplaning donc du
moins que le smartphone marche c'est ça
qui permet de faire la suite et de
commencer à regarder différentes
catégories de produits etc mais on a
toujours eu cette vision de la point de
vue écosystème certaines personnes se
plaignent parce que je dis ouais
l'écosystème vous avez parlé au tout
début etc on voit pas vraiment ça ça
passe par avoir une équipe software
ultra bien défini et pour pouvoir scale
en termes de différents produits qu'on
va ramener sur cet écosystème et c'est
toujours dans les plans il faut juste
prendre le temps de faire les choses
bien et c'est quoi le prochain produit
l'écosystème qui arrivera après le
smartphone ah c'est quoi ça
dernière question j'aimerais que tu me
donnes une anecdote sur sur la marque
une anecdote qui peut te concentrer toi
type personnel un truc que tu as dit à
personne justement on développait le
Iwan et en fait on n'avait pas à faire
un dessin différentiant sur le boîtier
en faisant les écouteurs et toute la
partie de la glue qu'il fallait pas que
ce soit visible vous les composants
internes sur le les écouteurs qu'il
fallait trouver le bon partenaire qui
voulait aller dans ce niveau d'État etc
c'était énormément compliqué donc en
fait on avait fini les écouteurs et là
fallait s'attaquer au boîtier des
écouteurs et là ça a été un petit peu le
Forest en interne parce que du coup tu
avais l'équipe produit enfin les
ingénieurs gênant enfin on nous a pris
beaucoup plus de prévu pour les
écouteurs au Japon j'aime pouvoir faire
le lancement on va partir sur un truc
basique donc c'était vraiment un boîtier
carré quoi et à l'époque on était une
petite équipe et
ultra tendue
comment les faire des produits dans tes
fier on voulait faire un design qui
allait vraiment différencier etc et du
coup l'équipe la partie de l'équipe qui
voulait faire allez vraiment jusqu'au
bout de l'idée et amener cette étudiant
du dévisuel qui était pour notre premier
produit c'était important qu'il fallait
vraiment chose qui sort du lot et un
produit qui vraiment représente la
vision d'une entité design de Nothing
c'était super important c'est vrai tu de
réfléchissais cette décision là est-ce
que bah du coup si on avait été avec la
facilité est-ce qu'on serait là
aujourd'hui en train de discuter et
c'est vrai que au final tu as plein de
petites décisions à des moments
critiques qui ont été prises on est
prises je sais pas si ça aurait si on
aurait pu parce que du coup le premier
produit c'était vendu à plus de 500 000
500 000 pièces et ouais
sans les one il y aurait jamais eu de
fond noir etc donc voilà c'est ça s'est
joué un petit décision pour moi je pense
si on avait fait l'autre si on avait
pris l'autre décision sur se repasser la
manière dont le lancement c'est pas si
ma manière générale et voilà pour la
petite anecdote c'est incroyable